venez là alors tenez bon tenez là bien
sûr laquelle venait là on aime tout cela
change et dont le public sur ma route
assez la chanson que je préfère
actuellement on la passe 30 fois par
jour sur le plateau ça c'est sûr fois
par jour dans cette émission parce qu'on
aime black m
et on aime quand thierry moreau n'aime
pas les chansons et qu'on peut se venger
alors thierry mauron vous avez critiqué
la chanson black m la semaine dernière
puisqu'on vous avez une semaine pour
réviser les paroles de cette chanson
vous allez jouer à n'oubliez surtout pas
les paroles donc première fois il
manquera un mot puis deux puis trois
puis quatre puis cinq et il y à une
pyramide de gages
alors attention amener les gages s'il
vous plaît bien sûr on y fait bien sûr
je crois qu'il va se régaler blake est
donc il ya alors il y a donc le le plein
dans l'assiette avec la tarte à la crème
si voilà c'est pour le deuxième os à ces
deux mots manquants alors je me tiens
première manche il ya deux moments quand
si vous répondez malplaquet vous
dessinera une moustache au chocolat
trois mots manquants bandes de cire pour
épilation du torse vous inquiétez pas on
trop à mes louis mais rask quelques
poils il reste quelques trucs vous
inquiétez pas on trouvera les jambes
c'est quatre moments quand on veut bien
les jambes quatre mots manquants tarte à
la crème et cinq moments quand le poulpe
sur la tête voilà il ya une odeur
d'ailleurs c'est une horreur attention
on y va envoyez la musique c'est parti
mais on y va
sur ma route oui il ya le move
oui de l'aventuré en route mais
je ne compte plus je ne compte plus quoi
je ne compte plus quoi thierry mots s'il
vous plaît je ne compte plus court je ne
compte plus quoi aller si on peut tirer
plus vite quitté les choses je ne
complique quoi les tonnes de mazout ont
des trajets déjà là deux mots je ne
compte plus sur je ne compte plus les
soucis les sociétés souci une barbe
c'est une moustache attention on
continue encore et cela les voici la
nouvelle chaire partie oliva j'ai eu des
moments de doute marché sans savoir vers
où je mettais plus rien atteint
sur ces 2,2 sur ma route quand on
parlait report je n'avais pas d'eux
n'avait pas de bagages en soute
bonjour je n'avais pas deux
attention troisième manche il ya
maintenant quatre mots qui manquent on
lui a dit entre nous sur ma bouche la
vérité j'ai souvent trébucher est ce que
tu sais que quand tu touches fourmies à
vous de juger qui tu peux te réfugier tu
peux compter
alors je peux compter que tu peux
compter 3 qui a une histoire de la
famille ouais c'est pas je venais pas
les ouvrir à nos familles le mot c'est
pas la famille à les attentions des amis
et ouais mais tu peux compter que sur
sur sur à les amis la famille je sais te
tuer' des amis la famille la chanson
serait dire pouvait compter que sur les
amis la famille est un peu pourri bien
sûr on joue pour la découvrir la crème
et aux alors vous avez vu ce qu'elle a
dit est ce qu'il a dit blake tarte à la
crème c'était bien sûr tu peux pas aller
voilà terrible
yes est ce que j'ai à dire je vous jure
il a répliqué tout l'après midi sera
marquée chaque monde maintenant on joue
pour le poulpe là là là bas débit
latorre vous avez été sauvées gt3 et le
pool c'est rien c'est que toutes les
bonnes choses reçoit lui est propre
sur ma ouvrés
alors facile seul compte plus les soucis
connaît tout le monde connaît alors vous
allez réaliser tout l'après midi
allez sur ma route je ne compte plus les
soucis ne s'est pas pour louis quoi bon
alors c'était sûr baroud
je ne compte plus les soucis de quoi
devenir fou oui
awilo pas devenir fou oui alors allez-y
black m je vous laisse moi je donne
parce que moi on attends moi j'ai jemma
chemin gare et non alors on joue pas
convaincu
la calandre